こんにちははじめ社長ですはい何があった
かと言いますと動画のタイトルにもある
通りなんですけど
この前の動画ですねこの動画の本当に前の
動画で
何なんだろうもうあの
北
disっ配りしたんですよティッシュ配り
始め社長のチャンネル登録お願いしますと
いう辞書頑張って手渡しで
自分で一番濃く貼らせていただいたんです
けど
ちょっとあの
見てないふりいがって来ないぐらいすごい
連絡がきましてすごいたくさんの人に肇
社長
配ってたティッシュがメルカリて売られて
ますよという連絡がそのたくさん来て自分
の実際に見てみたところ結構僕が実際に
自分で手渡ししたティッシュがメルカリで
売られていましたいろんな人にすごい転売
されてますけど
で連絡が来て
あの国があって私に渡した
ティッシュが
すごい数
結構な数がメルカリで売られていましたん
[音楽]
う
4 f
yeah
todo o
[拍手]
ヒュームわーっと部屋の
何から話せばいいのか
僕もよくわかんないんですけど
一回見てみましょうがメルカリちょっと
検索してみましょう
味見社長って言ったらティッシュが出て
くるんですよで押すとをご覧下さい
[音楽]
こう売られてますねそう思っており売れ
てるんだ僕手渡せしたブースがこのように
これ存在しないんで僕が渡した人の誰かが
みんな売ってるわけですよね目理解でどう
いう顔をしてみたらいいんでしょ1個
2500円で売れてますポケット
ティッシュがすごいよかなでの量が
メルカリで売られています
[音楽]
白板
すごいいろんなファンの方とか視聴者の方
からすぐ連絡来てあなたが私はティッシュ
テンパイされてますけど持って幽霊なんか
すごいたくさんくんですけども一つだけ
言わせてください
10倍じゃないですか10倍じゃない転売
ってどういうものかというと買ったものを
自分で買ったものをさらに他の人に
売り渡すことを転売って言うんですよ買っ
てそれは別の人に買ってもらうこれが好
10倍て全部するぞ1000倍なんです
けども今回僕が配ったはじめ冊を塗って
一緒に関しては儲かってないんですね僕
から僕が一方的に揚げたものなんですよ
一方的にいろんな人にチャンネル登録お
願いしますってあのティッシュ自分で
頑張って配ってそれを売ってるだけなんで
10倍ではない by です連絡
メッセージとかリップくれる時初めて
務めるカレーでティッシュが by され
てますって打っていただけるところが
正しい表現になりますて場合じゃないん
です bye ですこれを着ている動い
勝つの物価で渡したティッシュがメルから
で今by されてますバーイどうするんで
すかってくるっていうどうじゃないじゃん
荒野のどうしようもないんですもう僕が
またしたものなのでその人たちにその方に
渡したので私どもの道使わがその人の自由
なのであの
まあ私た本人からするとちょっと悲しい
気持ちはありますけども掃除機それを
売ろうが捨てようが友達に進めようがその
人も梅雨なんでまぁ個人的な意見を言うと
悲しいですけれども別にいることは悪い
ことではないとは思ってますちょっと
悲しいんですよね
誰だちゃんと顔見て手渡ししたんでみんな
の顔わかるんですけど別にあの丸いと思っ
てますね私はまったくまったく悪いとは
思ってないですしむしろもう一個ちょっと
なんか驚いたのかね値段値段がすごい驚い
てみてくださいこれ一番高いのでこれとか
も1個で2500円で売れてるんですよ
2,555円でしょすー来いよやばい
ポケットティッシュ一つか済車ツアーでも
て持たせしたかなっていうのがあるから
ちょっと色んな理由でこの値段なのかも
しれないですけどポケットでしゅ1個が
2000円で売れるってこんな光景
でしょうあります話せてるより高いですよ
もちろんの by されているのは凄い
あの渡した身としてはちょっと悲しいん
ですけどもでもそれ強いだと g だと
思いますし何よりでそのティッシュが購入
値段明らかに高いじゃないですかこういう
値段で買ってくださる方がいるっていうの
も正直すぐありがたいというか嬉しい
嬉しいおかしいけど悲しいって独立しこう
いうのは撃っちゃう人もいるんだなって
いう思いもあるんですけども星になって
はじめシャツを乗ってシュ欲しいなんて
思ってくださる方もいるって言うな僕が
初旬に頑張ったらほんとで大変で頑張って
配ったティッシュを打っちゃう人がいるん
だなという気持ちどもうそんな金額でも
欲しいと思ってくださる方がいるあって
いう嬉しい地持つ
大きいくださいフレデリックで悲し嬉しい
ありがたい禁物と悲しい気持ちがう
入り混じっている感じです
俺ポジティブかこれポジティブかもしれな
けどなんかその10倍っていうこと自体は
良くないと思うんですよ補正ものが買え
ない人がいるの前提で取れお値段を上げて
売るのはやっぱり良くないけどティッシュ
に関してはこれ売ってないんでお金貰って
ないんでも随分を上げたくて上げたものな
んで朝夕そのティッシュをどう使おうか
もうその人の自由なんで俺は売ってる人誰
も悪いとは思ってないですなんだから聞い
たったんじゃないって思っちゃうぐらいた
んですけどなんかでパッと見ただけば
悲しかったですけどあれでも俺なんか買っ
てもらったわけでもないし挙げたからそう
いう人はそれをどう使おうかはもうその人
の自由だからやっすごいな猫を持たより
売られてますね結構早く出されたものも
売れてますでも最近れたのはまだちょっと
残ってます1個ぐらい買って来ずいぶんで
いろんな人に配ったわけですよティッシュ
配りそれはもちろんはじめ殺王が好きだと
いう人もいらっしゃいますし始めシャツを
知らないという人にもたくさん渡したんで
悪いとは思っておりません今回10倍でも
ないですし by ですたまたまもらった
ものを打っただけなんにも悪くないただ
私の心は
傷ついた取るだけの話でございます何なら
それってちょっと需要があってちょっと
うれしい何位なんでとりあえずあの配らせ
ていただいた始めちゃ損でしょ破格の高級
ティッシュ皆さんチャンネル登録よろしく
お願いします次変わる時は価格が安くなる
ようにもっとたくさん組まれますpadi
padi
[音楽]
うぇっ
は